so last week in our staff meeting the
conversation came about after we were
reading the book contagious and I asked
a question from everybody I said hey can
you tell me why I make it a requirement
for us to read a book a month we've been
doing it for seven and a half years why
and I've got four responses one of them
says Pat you want us to prove I said
okay great
what else the other person said you want
our minds to be working and thinking
about work when we're after hours that
was an interesting one said another
person said you know it brings us
together because we're advancing
advancing together another person said
ideas and I said everything is great but
let me tell you why we read books I said
I want all of you to want to make more
money how many you guys want to make
more money they raised on that remember
this is not sales this is w2 job how
many of you want to ask for raise and to
get a raise and everyone said I want to
get a raise now this is me teaching my
staff how to ask for raise I said
there's three things that you need to be
doing to constantly be advancing in your
career and if you don't you're not going
to dance in your career they said what
is it and I wrote it out so I'm sure
they're not with you one is attitude
effort and progress let me explain
attitude you'll have you have a lot of
talented people in your career that
you'll hire I've hired so many
incredibly ridiculous talented people
with bad attitudes and they don't last
and they don't last anywhere they go
because anywhere they go nobody likes
them no one likes a bad attitude so when
it comes down to attitude a saving grace
for a person not to get fired it's a
positive attitude because you got three
opportunities with attitude what is a
person that comes in they're not
positive they're not negative it's just
no one knows they're around
nobody does you can walk by their
cubicle 50 times and they get fired one
day and you don't even know they got
fired because no one knows their
attitude because you never see them
because they don't say anything so
there's not a positivity or negativity
at least you remember the negative
person and remember the positive person
but you don't remember them person in
the neutral right negative once
eventually they're contagious any time I
look at a resume somebody gives me a
resume to hire I look at how many jobs
this person's had the last two
three four five years if it's multiple
jobs one after another after another
after another there is something there
this can't contribute accompany
companies don't let go of good people
they just don't I want to keep good
people there's something that didn't
work out there six different times and
most of the time it comes down to
attitude so then positive attitude we
had an employee in the room and I said
hey let me talk to you guys about her I
pointed at her and I said you know you
almost got fired six months ago four
months ago she said yeah I know I said
how do you know it says everybody told
me this I'm about to get fired I said
you know why you didn't get fired she
said why so I had an executive meeting
meeting with the executives get fired a
person is get fired let's keep these
three let's give a raise to this person
etc it said we have these meetings I
said you were on the verge of getting
fired because you had no clue what you
were doing with your job and she said
Jana see I had no idea I said but the
only reason why we didn't fire you is
because you have such a positive
attitude you're contagious to be run
I said that's your saving grace you have
no idea how valuable that is and she's
like oh my gosh this is so amazing I
said you stay like that you're going to
do great things with your life the next
one is effort let me explain to you the
effort you know with the guys in the
middle or I call them 759 - 501 big
bucks in a minute before and they cost
yet a minute after I gotta go watch my
TV shows and there's no way in the world
I'm working one minutes more for this
corporation and I'm supposed to I'm not
doing that I'm just not doing that right
it's like a religion to them still cool
you're a negative because these guys on
the bottom you know what they do let me
tell you bout their effort these guys
for whatever reason they're sick on
Mondays and they don't feel too well on
Friday afternoons I don't know what it
is their timing is incredible on when
they don't feel well right now I've
worked jobs before and I know why on
Mondays because you want to have a
longer weekend and I know why Fridays
because you want to have a longer
weekend but eventually people figure
that part out I mean everyone knows
what's going on there these guys they
always move up I remember working at
many of my jobs that it goes back to if
we have to do a certain thing at Bally's
and I was off at 8 o'clock or 9 o'clock
or 10 o'clock I was there till midnight
I don't have to be there till midnight I
didn't get paid those hours no one paid
me for those hours but I
to midnight now what happened when I
stayed there till midnight one I grew
for myself but people started saying
past one the hardest-working guys in the
company I became the Rookie of the Year
I got recognition I got those accolades
but you know what else happened let me
tell what else happened it crept me that
one day if I was ever going to be put
into an executive position I already
know about the effort part I'm not
afraid of working hard I don't mind
putting in 12 13 14 16 hour days because
I've done it it's a muscle now I'm
always going to be needed because most
people don't work that hard so for you
watching this I promise you these two
alone you're going to move up in your
career I promise you that because most
people don't work too hard and most
people don't consistently have a
positive attitude these two you'll learn
the other parts now let's get to the
last one last one is progress progress
to me as I call them meaning and its
meaning I say these five people I want
to be part of this meaning we're going
to do an aviation meeting on a new
software on a new technology on a new
system on a new product on a new show on
whatever I sit there as a person we'll
call the meeting and I watch on who's
giving feedback the person that doesn't
give feedback I don't invite to the next
meeting for what you don't get feedback
what's the purpose of you sitting there
to look pretty I mean this is we don't
get paid to model here right we get paid
to come up with ideas okay cool the
person that constantly comes up with
ideas and they don't get shut they don't
get what's the data to what do you call
it when somebody gets idea shut down and
they become defensive and they they
don't freeze and then you know how
somebody said no we can't do the idea
right now and they go like this because
they're too sensitive now instead this
person says oh okay cool no problem you
know boom neck so sometimes some ideas
are just not workable and they keep
feeding more and keep feeding more like
men this dude's got a great idea
he's so enthusiastic about being here
and it's working hard any given great
ideas trifecta like this guy they keep
them long-term
let's give a more responsibility a move
up among the company give a raise that's
the progress how can I make me better
how can I make the company better how
can I make the industry better how can I
make this thing go faster how can I make
this thing look better how can we make
the process safe how can we make this a
formal place how can we go that
everything is about better better better
better better and the one on the
autumn is the one that walks through and
says oh my gosh I hate working here did
you hear what he said again here it goes
again
do you know what he said oh here we go
see you don't understa bitching bitching
bitching bitching bitching bitching
bitching these two become best friends
they're typically the same person
somehow someway they join the same club
I don't know what it is they attract
each other but these guys somehow
someway always move up I can't tell you
why it is it's just what it is so if
you're watching this right now whether
you're an entrepreneur whether you're a
businessman whether you're successful
already an executive whether you're
running a company that did 180 million
dollars last year revenues and you're
feeling like it's great always go back
and take an inventory of yourself and
the people on your team how's the
ideation of you concentrating on ways to
make things better how is your effort
being put in how's your attitude take
the assessment of your people and the
people that are there help them move up
and if you're somebody that's not doing
these 3 try to become a trisect ask
yourself every day how's my attitude it
has my effort today how am i becoming
better at making idea to progress in the
company and the more you do that if the
company you're working out right now
treats you like crap and and I'm talking
sincerely not you watch yeah that's why
I'm not moving up in life where you're
really lazy I'm talking you got a great
positive attitude regularly you
regularly work hard and you always
comment on what ideas and they still
don't treat you well eventually
someone's going to take notice that I
promise you eventually someone's going
to take notice you're gonna move up it's
inevitable to law it works for everybody
so just focus on these three areas Mario
let's get our favorite pillow okay today
we have Mario throwing us two pillow
instead of Paul we got two new team
members here behind us one likes you
said comedy he likes comedy and this one
wants to be a producer is what he wants
to be and we just talked about the
question why Dana cook Dane Cook
why Dane Cook is no longer he has to
been on the scene for a while Mario gave
us some feedback why did some of you
guys may remember that because some of
you guys know but regardless if you
haven't yet subscribed to this channel
this if I'm doing this right am i doing
all right is this good here the guys are
trying to critique me on where to pull
my finger
click here to
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
joined a notification squad the crazy
notification squad that within 30
seconds of video going up you guys are
messaging click on the alert to be one
the first for YouTube to alert you every
time a new video goes up and join the
notification squadron if you got
questions comments thoughts comment on
the bottom take everybody go by
[Music]